et c'est la question de savoir si
l'avortement est en droit et quand c'est
en droit et s'il y a des pays qui connu
en fait qui connaissent l'avortement
comme un droit donc malgré notre
tendance à faire référence au droit à
l'avortement quand on parle de
l'avortement euh dans les lois
l'avortement en fait est rarement
reconnu comme un droit en soi dans le
droit international on parle souvent de
principes des droits humaines à
respecter autour de soin lié à
l'avortement mais on ne connaît pas
l'avortement pour l'instant et en soit
comme un droit pourtant quelques pays
dans le monde considèrent et trait
l'avortement comme unendroit et il
s'agit souvent des pays soit
post-soviétiques comme l'Arménie
Azerbaïdjan Kazakistan Turkménistan et
la Russie ainsi que des pays où
l'avortement a été récemment légalisé
comme l'Argentine et le Népal et
finalement aussi le Vietnam et l'Islande
donc en Arménie Kazakistan Turkménistan
et en Islande les lois font référence
soit au droit à l'interruption de
grossesse ou droit à l'interruption
artificielle de grossesse la loi au
Vietnam stipule que les femmes ont le
droit à l'avortement et au Népal la loi
affirme que les femmes ont le droit à
l'avortement sécurisé donc ce dernier
donc le cas de Népal en fait fait
référence à quelque chose bien attesté
dans la recherche sous l'avortement
c'est à savoir que là où l'avortement
est interdit l'interdiction de
l'avortement n'empêche pas les
avortements de se produire mais les
rendent plutôt dangereux et clandestin
donc en fait ce qui reste aux loi et aux
politiques publique si vous voulez c'est
de décider si les avortement seront
pratiqués de manière sécurisée et non et
c'est cette langage qu'on observe dans
les loi euh au Népal donc la deuxième
chose que je vou le souligner est le
fait que même si l'avortement est
rarement reconnu comme un droit en soi
il y a quelques pays qui le font et on
peut aussi faire ce choix en France ici